okay babies okay anyways it's your boy
psychobabble and today we're gonna play
a little game called captive audience
okay um anyways this is pretty
interesting game it looks like it's from
Ezio and it is like this weird game
that's not really that advertised I have
no idea why I saw like five minutes of
gameplay and it looks so sweet
apparently it's supposed to be like a
psychological horror and I am super
excited about this okay let's just do
this then launch the game right now to
make it nice and fresh for you people I
know how you people love the fresh
content okay I just now yeah I know how
you love it you know it's very simple
I've got this music okay we're gonna
start episode 1 who do what a fresh
start with a fresh start okay has some
good soda and some horrible music okay
now wake it up okay here we go Bebe's
I mean you're talking about that cat
okay whoa four okay I'm excited oh my
god
I just love that guy that kind of pretty
cut yeah Wow you're not like polish
thank you I'm pretty good okay that's
not delicious I'm actually really
excited better get to it man don't want
to have the folks at home going at a log
oh this place is dope dude oh my god
why would this ever be bad hey babies
let's go this nice little opus that's uh
that's what I'm talking about
okay stop sugar flour egg egg okay let's
do this I got some of this salt you're
gonna rotate this right do this [ __ ]
okay enough of that
enough of that yeah better proprietary
hit this hop anyway you know
perfect I'm sugar sugar handing out
[ __ ] sugar over there um you know
can't get some of this flour sugar syrup
okay here you go baby easy does it
a sugar a day keeps the doctor away I
have some flour
I can't easy a day say no this looks
like gasoline but it's flour now I can't
hear I got it thank you thank you very
much it's easy it's it's really easy
eggs take some of these bad boys right
here good EP goody thank good good get
that hey just just put the whole [ __ ]
shell on it everybody loves the show
here we go ah
oh just doesn't seem [ __ ] right okay
wow that's disgusting but if they're
making me put in it they're making me
put it in baby oh [ __ ] I didn't just
ruin the batch it's normal milk milk
okay so milk is our daddy yeah okay um
yes okay
butter okay you're not just put the
whole [ __ ] thing in here you know you
know what I mess it up by having too
little butter and coloring how does this
help this is [ __ ] Khloe and I catch
up okay okay you got that right Jane
that [ __ ] it burn yourself holy cannoli
this is like that's how I worked at
Amsterdam how are you gonna do it for
the fans yeah do everything really [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] it hurts
holy [ __ ] does it hurt oh my god I can't
even [ __ ] think
oh that's [ __ ] s oh yeah is that
frosting thank you
okay close - [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah where you
go oh I got it's perfect
oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah come on
I'm [ __ ] professional am I saying
that oh my god [ __ ] disgusting I
better clean the dishes what is all this
[ __ ] is that better myself
huh turn that on I have a [ __ ]
oh hello sir
try dinner I want you to record this one
riling stats okay okay can I go in here
no I cannot I visit Cuba always I've
always wanted to okay I guess that's it
well I would the [ __ ] bathroom yeah
this is nice
yeah should we go through other people's
[ __ ] [ __ ] my talkative here [ __ ] for a
second that was this little [ __ ]
talking to me
hey when I say it was that's alright you
know can't complain you know everyday
goes to one 401k a little bit how about
you nice my Chinese should fix this back
from Mike if I not [ __ ] my [ __ ] ear
pieces check that kitchen no I'm not
done like that promise come on come on
let me help anyone
what the frog didn't say what the Frog
didn't know but no it took my cake
what hello la [ __ ] who is this [ __ ]
witness das no you [ __ ] art and here's
closing this jet ski Wow this entire
place is like a fortress they'll just
punish me if I try anything what is that
all right
[ __ ] yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
anywhere here
and running
that's good
typical
holy [ __ ] that nap [ __ ] they got me
[Music]